okay question who do you think who do
you think cheats more men or women and
do they oh she's going to hit us with
statistics
who do you think cheats more men or
women and do they cheat differently i
think we cheat differently i think men
cheat more okay but we definitely cheat
differently yeah like i feel like and i
know it's gonna sound bad but when women
cheat is worse yeah i was gonna say that
i i knew you guys would say that their
argument is because when the girl cheats
because she has feelings for him he's
providing something about that but
that's usually what it is it's about
like it's about emotion it's about on
top of that like as a girl like when a
guy sleeps with a girl he just sleeps
with her you can you can just like you
can literally sleep with her even worse
when you guys
like if you were to cheat would you
cheat with someone other than your
boyfriend
no
there we go oh wait it depends
i'm sorry
depends on this no i was gonna say
so you're the first thing you see is
someone's attractiveness obviously but i
think if someone's
not better looking than your boyfriend
necessarily but he provides you with
something else emotionally you get more
traffic
you're going to say that's worse right
than cheating with someone that's the
point they're making is the guy has
something your boyfriend doesn't doesn't
okay
where a girl like like okay i always say
this like do you remember the day you
realized you had to worry about ugly
[ __ ] too
[Laughter]
you said it
look it like i was like you thought
but it's because like guys it's more of
like an instinct they're like oh god
boop like
boobs bump like ass i don't even like
see what she looks like
i don't even notice she was fat like
like that's what i'm saying like guys
it's more of just like an immediate
response where girls like we have to
connect with them on some level we have
some prerequisite for them sleeping with
us
it takes a while for a girl i think men
like have you ever have any of you ever
slept with a girl that you would never
want to be seen in public with yes
no no no i said that as a joke back me
how good are my standards they're
impeccable impeccable all my girls are
top three they're always top free
they're always set free
[Music]
okay what about you guys i haven't to be
fair i'm like my man i've got it
right he knows
i know like i was saying earlier like
there are guys that are dogs that they
will just sleep with anything just
just because they can or try and get
their numbers up or at uel name them
[Laughter]
wait put that put that on the floor
romeo turn off the camera
no don't be shy go ahead let's go ahead
yeah those guys obviously
they'll just sleep with girls at uni
just because they know or they know
she's easy like they're bored or they're
like horny or whatever they'll just
sleep with her
but yeah like girls aren't going to do
that
or less likely to anyways
don't think for guys like
that behavior usually
i'll say okay there are two types of
guys the guys that have like could get
girls from
a young enough age and they're really
really super late bloomers so i feel
like you always go for a phase where
it's like you're just you don't just go
for it
and then usually
that that that phase usually ends like
after uni whatever and then you're just
in life and you you can turn down sex
whereas those guys
who are super late bloomers are the ones
that like in their mid-20s and they're
just like they will literally go
anywhere and do anything and it's just
like it's the ones that got like they
had no girls at school and suddenly like
they're attractive now they start
hitting gym or whatever they can
suddenly get loads of girls and then
they just like don't know how to like
control it like what was composure
i said one thing i was like how do you
expect to play champions league games if
you don't play preseason
so you've got to build your levels up
you've got this conversation okay wait
can i can i clarify let me just
understand so crazy so you gotta sleep
with the uglier girls to get to the
hotter girls not to get them all but if
you're not on form
okay so like that's so like so you guys
are practicing i can't relate
so the ugly girls are like practice
not not me that's like it's like a
friend
it's like someone else that'd be bad
i would never
am i wrong no okay
ugly girls
[Laughter]
okay um
so okay do you guys think that um
because we were kind of talking about
how cheating is different for men and
for women right
um and i want to tie this back into
social media okay
do you think that it's cheating if a
girl is posting
ass pictures on the internet in a
relationship 100 that's cheating yeah
i wouldn't say cheating cheating is like
a strong word i would say that yeah i
feel like
i feel like it's disrespectful or like
yes she's overstepped her boundary i
wouldn't say like
she's cheating i think if that issue
you're air sorry no you show your ass on
the beach you know and then
what's the problem
that's the thing i know it's a very
thick line
about sharing it on instagram it's
calling for attention but then you again
you are proud of your body you want to
show it if you are over showing okay
that that recalls like for attention
like you're over posting about your ass
about your boobs about your body all the
time i get it but if you're sharing like
a bikini or a lingerie photos just you
know once in a while what's the problem
with that you are like you are proud
well i think i think it's just i think
but i think it just screams easy to man
to me it's like girls they aren't easy
in real life
if there's a thing where you like do gym
and stuff and like your personal
training like obviously you work your
bum and that's fair enough in it because
that's part of your brand your business
if you're just any normal girl and
you're posting a picture of your nyash
then listen yes
like why are you posting a picture of
your of your behind like that's
disrespectful
that's an open invitation for hella dms
hello
story replies i'm paying for a premium
account when it was on free trial
fax
that was a good analogy
no but like i feel like
girls often times mistake sexual
attention with like relationship
attention because
like they'll put this ass picture on the
internet one that's going to be there
forever like your kids like are going to
see that someday is that that what if a
guy posts like a topless pic or
something when he's in a relationship if
a guy does it if a guy does it i mean
okay
it's twofold right one yeah i don't
think i i do think it is
i do think it's kind of douchey
um but honestly i think it's a double
standard yes i think it's more cheating
for women than it is for men because
most men aren't going to get girls in
their like dms like that and i think if
you're a guy and you're posting a
topless picture that's one or two things
i have a hench because you've actually
worked for it
so it's just like fair enough like you
might be a bodybuilder whatever the hell
or you're like hella tired and it's just
like it's art not art but do you know
what i mean you're trying to show your
tattoos but you still want to you're
still on attention like you guys are but
it's not the same because girls don't
really
see like a chest and are like i want to
have sex with that like
like guys guys see an ass and like
the the you know it's it's wait so so
are you playing you might get like 20 30
replies i don't know how many i posted
like a chess but it might get like one
or two if that
i mean
that down to the fact that we're we're
always the ones pursuing whatever
whatever you do will lead to more than
what if we do something because girls
aren't going to make that first move
yeah because guys usually are moving to
girls rather than girls move into guys
yeah we're we're the sales people yeah
oh we are
low of averages anyway let me know
but i think like uh women are seen as
more as a sexual um
than men that's why in general let's
start there but if i see like a male
as a model like a really nice model and
i see and i like his body
you can actually get turned like in a
way like
sexy yeah i would do him why not like no
but
like
he crosses your mind sometimes he does
it's not just like as a yeah but okay
okay but it crosses your mind sometimes
it does right but that's that's of
course they see boobs and and above
they're like ah you know oh my god i'll
go there i would dive in i mean like
guys have a thing such as like a sex
doll
that's a thing that men purchased six
dollars a six dollars yeah yeah like a
girl would never buy that yeah
like yeah but you don't buy your little
toys and stuff
but yeah yeah girls have way more you
live with me you know i don't have one
no but i'm saying like men are more
attracted to like a body like that's
what i'm saying like like why do they
need that visual because like men are
more attracted to like
like they're more visual than women yeah
sure
i mean
who's gone for a guy that's ugly but
funny
oh just
i have
i have yeah yeah
that's because women fall in love with
what they hear men fall in love with
what they see
that's why i feel like it's a double
standard and it's different for men and
for women
i thought you were going to respond
no you said it perfectly perfectly
okay so um